Gary what do you think is the biggest
mistake a screenwriter can make I think
I don't know about the biggest mistake a
writer can make there are a lot of
mistakes writers can and do make one of
them is being a bit inebriated and and
and to grand about their work in the way
they communicate it to the world no one
wants to people want to discover they
want to be Columbus discovering the new
world and if you overstate the new world
and that you've already developed in
belt hotels and what they're gonna find
and they should come and it takes all
the fun out of being they've discovered
the Christopher Columbus so I would say
be you know be authentic be persuasive
but but don't overstate I think another
mistake that writers can make is
believing that other people know more
than you believing that other people
know the right way to do things or a
better way to do things is like no you
know yourself you know your project
better than anyone and you should if you
check with your gut in your brain both
be fully capable and competent to figure
out the best way to put that out into
the market market it and tell the story
around it no one can be you
I mean III think there are a lot of
mistakes that writers can make one of
them is is is wasting time and not being
as disciplined as they should be about
their output one of them is certainly
thinking that there's such a thing as
perfection hogwash you know you there's
there's a point at which I know people
have been rewriting a book or a script
or something for literally years plural
and that's not a good sign so I think
there's a you know look all of us are
capable of making lots of different
kinds of mistakes I think common sense
sort of is the answer to most of them
well I mean Susan Cain she's an attorney
and she wrote quiet yeah and she talked
about how she took seven years I think
to work on the book but she loved the
process and that was part of her being
an introvert and that's what the book is
about as is is just delving into sort of
this own were her own little world and
writing and researching and all that was
so seductive to her whereas knowing that
she had to get it out there well that
was something that's the total sort of
hurt her it's hard to introvert if we
cringe at that study everyone's
different there's you know you're asking
me you know by the nature of an
interview you're asking me questions
that are as broadly applicable hopefully
as they can be and you know what's true
Susan Cain or JK Rowling or this one or
that one is not going to be true for 90%
of the audience
you know but but yeah I mean the thing
about a Susan Cain and certain others is
they kept genuinely enhancing and
improving and putting more meat on the
bone Susan didn't waste the last three
years out of those seven years just
cuddling her manuscript right what that
wasn't her process but but most people
who spend seven years on anything I can
almost guarantee you have wasted a lot
of time right it's very individual well
just wrapping up just quickly you'd said
something earlier about you know the
person who's too grandiose versus then
the person who thinks that they everyone
else knows more than they and David and
I happen to be having a very similar
conversation in the car about how
there's just got almost like two types
of people and I've said it before in
interviews but finding that middle
ground because you owe you know the
braggart you know the one that's this is
the next best thing and that person is
usually had a cocktail party and that's
the one you move away from and then you
know the one that probably has a lot of
really interesting things to say but you
can't get it out of them because they
don't believe in themselves and they're
closed off their arms are closed and
it's almost like they want to go into a
corner so how do we how do we find that
middle balance because I think a lot of
times these personality types don't know
that they are that way and I think if
you could take that braggart and make
them a little more take them down on the
scale rather take the quiet one and make
them talk a little more make them more
grandiose yeah cuz I can guarantee it
the the person who's and we I get this a
lot you know and here's the good news
it's not just a script it's a trilogy
and guess what I've already figured out
the merchandising and guess what it's
guaranteed to make a hundred million
dollars at the box office you are so
lucky
that I'm offering you this project it's
like please get out of my inbox that's
never gonna happen
I remember Lilly Tartikoff after Brandon
Tartikoff died who was almost
unparalleled in for who he was and how
people embraced him he was beloved
everything about him his intelligence
his creativity his personality his very
down to earth quiet ways charming and
created the most successful Network in
the history of television and brought
more innovation to to bear than anyone
who had come before
and I remember Lilly Tartikoff in an
interview talking about she was sitting
she met him at this big party I think
was it live Wasserman's or some some big
persons home and everybody else was very
you know in the moment and there was
this one guy very quiet guy off in the
corner sort of keeping to himself really
not talking and she just zeroed in on
him and said that's the one right and
went over and met him and sure enough
right
jf Lawton was the same way I met lot not
because he was a writer I hired him to
program my Macintosh which was you know
like in the mid 80s it was one of the
first ones and he you couldn't plug the
sucker it didn't do anything and a
writer friend of mine happen to use the
Mac and I asked how did you who program
that and she said this guy I called this
guy and it was jf Lawton he literally
sat by my side worked in my office
non-stop for three weeks programming
learning everything about my life what I
did how I did it what I wanted and what
I needed he knew everything about it so
he knew my work but he never mentioned
that he was a writer he had seven
scripts sitting in his little one-room
studio he was that quiet brilliant
shy guy who was just that he was so
gifted it was ridiculous but you had to
pull it out of him and I did but you
have to sort of just notice things you
know there's there's this wonderful
Daniel Goleman who wrote emotional
intelligence gave a talk and he talks
about I forgot what camps it was a
campus back East somewhere in the United
States where they have a seminary as
well and they did an experiment and in
this experiment they divided the
seminary students into two groups and
they told both groups that they were
going to develop and deliver that same
day a sermon but to the control group a
they said on any topic of your choosing
but to control Group B they said you're
going to deliver a sermon based on the
parable of the Good Samaritan well we
all know the parable of Israel so they
were both sent off to to spend a certain
amount of time crafting their sermon and
after a certain amount of time they were
told okay it's time to leave we're gonna
go to the chapel which is the far side
of the campus and then we're gonna walk
these curving walkways across campus to
the to the chapel and so they did but
along the path right off the walkway on
the lawn writhing in fetal position was
a somewhat older man obviously in bad
shape in pain
the study was to see how many and which
students stopped and why and those who
didn't stop why didn't they stop one
would logically think that those who
stopped were the ones who were writing
the parable about the parable of the
Good Samaritan because that was their
mindset but that wasn't it all true what
was true I said of those who stopped and
those who didn't there was one
consistent reality the students who did
not feel prepared who are anxious who
were consumed who were not ready to
deliver their sermon who were lost in
their thoughts about what am I gonna do
they didn't notice this person on the
ground they literally didn't notice and
so they continued along the walkway the
students who felt ready confident
self-contained about this idea they
walked and they were observing and
noticing everything around them because
they were free and present and they
noticed this man on the ground writhing
in pain and they stopped had nothing to
do with the Good Samaritan it had to do
with the fact that we in the modern age
notice so much less because we're so
busy on so many levels that we miss a
lot of life we miss opportunity we must
people we miss community we miss so much
just because we don't notice
I would say there's this there's there's
a lesson in there for those who aspire
to a creative career
but I wouldn't say that to them
[Laughter]
you